symtrax grosse école bâtie six nations
qui font ça fatigue alors le siège aux
dessous c'est juste ces moments-là
négatif que je me suis dit ah mais
l'école même si j'aimais l'école parce
que gemelli contre j'aime et sans
apprendre des choses peu importe qu
est-ce que c'était l'indignation était
un gros point négatif faisons en sorte
que des fois j'avais dit matin voit ce
que je voulais pas me lever que je les
parents à l'école je voulais pas rentrer
dans l'autobus j'aime pas la vie annonce
devance donc frapper mais misent ainsi
d'entendre ça me répugne et danzé pour
ce jeudi jean bosson parce que je
l'épaule façon je préciserai du temps et
ça m'a fait réaliser qu'il ya d'autres
moyens pour en fait c'est la première
fois où est-ce que par les moyens autres
que la violence l'intimidation l'arrêter
pour beaucoup plus longtemps quelques
jours passés dans son camp je lis quand
je frappe et si on veut plus haute il
est arrêté parce que je savais que
j'allais la directrice pendant plusieurs
jours justement petit temps georges
dangereux quelques enjeux les échos
la punition était fini elle lève
commencer les lieux avec la leçon
justement ça m'a appris que non frappé
c'est pô juste entre autres en quatrième
année j'ai avait été frappé j'ai
commencé réellement à parler aux
professeurs beaucoup plus pour dénoncer
mais estime nathan puis en dentelle
c'est la france ça marche et d'une
certaine manière parce que maintenant
que je dénonce et chacun de l'entente y
arriver parce que les rendre compte que
m'emmener à force d'en parler à l'espace
vraiment se faire soigner